shout out to Bo nickel well they do next
with them I think he's a top 15 I
actually personally think he's the top
10 guy right now but again there's no
sense in seeing if he is you know even
though if I say that or the UFC raps
thinks that there's no point in pushing
him into the top 15 right now what you
would do with a guy like that is give
give him not wood burns on you know a
guy who's cutting Lawns coming off you
know the regional circuit but you'd give
them more UFC vets and see how he does
but at this rate you know keep building
it boxing does this well keep building
the hype and keep building the star
because he has a pretty established fan
base you keep building that and then
when it's time you you put them in there
against the top 15 but at this rate you
know he could fight 10 times a year you
know just starching these guys in 30
seconds he's just no real deal in every
facet man he's the next face of the UFC
I would bet a lot of money on that